[موسيقى]
هو فن مصري اصلا هي مش موجوده في العالم
كله هم حاولوا يعملوا الشغلة دي اصلا على
المكنه ما عرفوش يعني وانا عندي كده يعني
حوالي حاجه وعشرين عملنا كسره الكعبه في
حوالي
68 69 كده عملنا كسره الكعبه صنعاء حاليا
بتنقرض يعني في ناس بتتعلمش
[موسيقى]
انا اسم محسن شعبان الشهير بن محسن الخامس
بعمل الشغل ده شغل يدوي كله بالابره في
المهنه دي فوق الخمسين سنه يعني بتاع 55
سنه انا في المهنه دي وانا عندي ثمان سنين
اول ما بدات الشغل في المهنه دين كنت
بشتغل في الشغل اللي هو القماش اللي هو
بتاع الاسوينه اللي هو بتاع الفراشين اللي
هو كان بيتعلق في عمر مكرم في التحرير
فلما جه في حاجه وستين كده في السبعينات
جه القماش ده نام شويه
والطبع دلوقتي بيعملوه طبع عشان
الشغل ده بقى تقيل شويه وبعدين اتصنع
حاليا بتنقرض يعني في ناس بتتعلمش عملنا
الشغل ده اتركنا الشغل ده واشتغلنا بقى في
الشغل
اللي هو الايه العربي والاسلامي والخط
الكوفي والفرعوني كل شغل
بدانا ان احنا نشتغل في الشغل دوت على
اساس الشغل التركي اصلا وبعدين احنا اول
كمان ما اشتغلت في الصنعه دي يعني وانا
عندي كده يعني حوالي حاجه وعشرين عملنا
كسوه الكعبه بحوالي
كده عملنا قصه الكعبه باليدوي عملناها هنا
في شارع الخيميه انا اشتغلت فيها اصلا
شخصيا هو شغل الخيميه هو فن مصري اصلا وهي
مش موجوده في العالم كله اللي هم حاولوا
يعملوا الشغل دي اصلا مع المكنه ما يعرفوش
اللي لا طبعا لازم تلف كده وتيجي كده لازم
والمقص ولازم تشتغل ما ينفعش اللي هي تعمل
على المكنه دي شغل يعني في العالم بره ما
فيش حد فيها ميه اصلا بيعمل شغل الا هنا
في جمهوريه مصر العربيه
[موسيقى]
التصميم بتاعي بيحب انقل من معابد ومن
الجوامع يعني وفي كروته يعني انا لما بروح
بعمل شغل عربي اسلامي وشغل العربيه بروح
الجوامع يعني زي السلطان حسن الامام
الشافعي
الخياميه مرتبط اه برمضان وبيبقى عندنا
هنا يعني عندك بيبقى من اول رجب كده
وشعبان بتلاقي هنا زحمه هنا السوق او تحت
اللي هي الناس غاويه الحاجات اللي هي
المفارش دي والحاجات اللي هي بتيجي البهجه
بتاعه رمضان وبتديك مثلا كهرباء والفوانيس
يبقى على اساس لما بيجي يفطر بيبقى عايش
اكنه بيجو رمضان النهارده انا داخل على 73
سنه ما اعرفش العمره هيودينا فين فانا
خايف على الصنعه دي والمهنه دي ولو ماتت
حرام يعني النهارده الصنعه دي حرام اللي
هي تموز النهارده الشاب عايز هوب يروح
طالع على طول عايز يكسب عادي لان احنا
عندنا احنا اتعلمنا بالصبر يعني بص عدلتها
عامله ازاي قعد صبري تقعد كده 12 ساعه 10
ساعات فلازم يا ريت اللي هو يعملوا تدريب
مهني للشباب الصنعه الخياميه الشغل اللي
اليدوي على اساس يجيبوا شباب
نعلمه وانا عندي استعداد اللي انا هتطوع
اللي انا اروح اعلمه
[موسيقى]
الرسومات اللي بتطلب مني في شهر رمضان
الاكتريه اليفط والايات القرانيه
[موسيقى]
والدرويش اللي هي الصغيره والكبيره
والحاجات اللي هي القران اكتر اليوم في
القران اكتر في المائده بيعلقوها على اساس
يعني بيحطوا يقعد طمطمه بس انا ممكن
اعملها يدوي بيعملوها حاليا طبعا يعني
بيعملوها طبع وبتعمل يدوي والكرسي لها قصه
تانيه يعني دي برضو بيبقى في ناس غبيه
برده في رمضان على اساس يعني يرشحوها
يبقوا يكلمو اولادهم فيها ايه معنى قصه
جحا بيفهموهم كان بيعمل ايه بيساوي ايه
فانا عملنا القصه يعني اساسيه يعني دي
لوحه اساسيه فلازم نعملها على الاب بيعرف
الابن بيقول له دي ايه واساسها ايه ولما
ده عمل ايه وطلع ايه وركب ايه كده
بالطريقه دي يعني عندي حته زي دي تاخد يوم
شغل
دي مخده تاخد يوم شغل عندي حته تاخد شهر
عندي حته تاخد شهرين شغل عندي يعني حته زي
دين برضو تاخد يومين شغل عندي حته برضو زي
بط ميدوم ده بياخد يوم شغل فكل حاجه على
حسب كميه الشغل بتاعتي يعني في بياخد قليل
في بياخد كتير وفي بياخد شهرين بياخد
تلاته على حسب كوبري الشغل وضيقه الشغل
يعني ضيقه الشغل في شغل على واسع في شغل
على ضيق فده ليه وقته ده له وقته